en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en los
Juegos Olímpicos de París 2024 queda
poco más de un año un año casi justo y
los retos se multiplican para la capital
francesa para supuesta punto para ello
nos acompañan cuatro invitados en ese
estudio Ana María ospina periodista
especializada en deporte bienvenida
Gracias Carlos
compañera de France 24 bienvenida
gracias
con France 24 del servicio de deportes
bienvenido buenos y Ingrid Gamboa es
especialista del break dance es
consultora del Breaking olímpico para el
canal Euro Sport bienvenida Ingrid
Muchas gracias Carlos a un año de París
2024 y en Primera Plana
el sueño de conseguir una medalla bajo
la Torre Eiffel ya está más cerca para
muchos deportistas de todo el planeta
falta poco más de un año para que
arranque en aquí los Juegos Olímpicos y
los retos no son pocos las obras la
ecología los conflictos internos que han
llevado a la dimisión de la presidenta
del comité olímpico francés también la
seguridad en el centro de las
preocupaciones y qué decirles de la
presencia de atletas rusos que provoca
división en el deporte un deporte que se
abre en París a nuevas disciplinas por
primera vez es el caso del break dance
París 2024 contará con skateboarding y
con sharp que fueron dos disciplinas que
debutaron en Tokio 2020 deporte política
medioambiente todo se mezcla en unas
olimpiadas a un año de que empiece y que
todo el planeta ponga sus ojos en la
capital francesa repasemos algunas
portadas diario el equipo hagan juego
billetería alojamiento de atletas
infraestructura París entra en la recta
final de la preparación otra polémica
subraya este artículo de lemont
requisición de 3000 habitaciones
estudiantiles para los Juegos Olímpicos
le pasión se hace en esta portada la
pregunta que todos nos hacemos Estará
listo París para la gran cita Bueno pues
Ana les trasladó directamente esa
pregunta Estará listo París para esa
gran cita qué es lo que más miedo da que
no llegue a tiempo Carlos los Juegos
Olímpicos y paralímpicos de París 2024
si creemos las palabras de la alcaldesa
de París sano Hidalgo sí estarán listos
qué es lo que puede dar más dificultad
en esta hora el transporte público hago
énfasis en esto que son de las obras más
atrasadas que se tienen el acceso para
las personas con alguna discapacidad y
algunas líneas de metro que parece que
no estarían listas y que tendrían ese
inconveniente de transportar a los
atletas y a los más de un millón de
visitantes
hay inquietud por algo Natalia por agua
con lo que no se llega a tiempo hay que
fiarse de las palabras de la alcaldesa
en Hidalgo
hay que fiarse yo creo que Ana María
tiene mucha razón porque uno que vive
aquí en París ve también que el avance
de los de las obras tampoco es que vaya
muy rápido ahora por haber hablado con
algunos de los que están encargados de
las obras ya por ejemplo de la Villa
Olímpica Ellos dicen que no tienen
digamos margen digamos de de tiempo pero
que están a tiempo con la con las obras
Aunque hay algunos algunos sitios por
ejemplo el que se está construyendo por
la Chapel en donde dicen que ha habido
unos tiempos que un poco de retraso
también por la guerra en Ucrania y cosas
que por ejemplo de de materiales de
materias primas que no han podido llegar
a tiempo y eso hizo que bueno tengan que
correr un poco más pero ahora que
esperar si si todas esas instalaciones
van a estar listas solo en estos días
van a inaugurar todo un sector de la
Villa Olímpica en esos días O sea que ya
un año antes ya ya la Villa Olímpica
está casi lista en cualquier caso
cualquier retraso se soluciona poniendo
dinero encima de la mesa con sobrecostes
dada la importancia de unas olimpiadas
es decir llegar se llega otra cosa es
que se aumente la factura y qué pasa con
estos sobrecostes donde acaban en el en
el en la cuenta del ciudadano hay una
parte que llega de la venta de las
boleterías
se está esperando que mil doscientos
millones de euros aproximadamente vengan
de ese rublo es decir un tercio de ese
presupuesto seguramente más adelante lo
vamos a abordar eso también ha hecho que
algunos precios se pueda ver elevados en
este sentido Y más allá del sobrecosto
es que se hagan trabajo doble es que
tengan que pagar a más obreros para que
los trabajos avancen hay una ventaja que
también tiene París que hay que
mencionarlo que muchas de las
infraestructuras que van a ser
utilizadas para los Juegos Olímpicos ya
está siendo utilizadas entonces ahí
construcciones que no hay que hacer y
eso hace pues que los trabajos vayan más
rápido la alcaldesa ha dicho que esta
semana esta semana que París está lista
en respuesta a las dudas planteadas por
un responsable del coi Cuáles son las
inquietudes fundamentales del koi Román
pienso que el punto negro de París ahora
es un postre de hecho hay tres líneas
que no van hacia listas tuve la línea 16
17 que se supone juntaba
Así que eso es el punto negro porque yo
antes el tiempo de los impíos va a ser
un día muy ocupado para 15 días en el
verano va a ser un desafío para la eatp
la presencia de atletas rusos divide al
mundo del deporte otra polémica como
están actuando las diferentes
federaciones Ingrid en el Breaking ya
todo el mundo está hablando de eso y
está muy la comunidad está hablando de
de Tal vez porque los rusos Son muy
fuertes es una nación muy fuerte en
Breaking están esperada entonces todo el
mundo está sosteniendo a los a los rusos
y hasta vimos un juez ucraniano y un
juez ruso hace poco juzgar a una
competición juntos pero en principio El
coi apuesta porque compitan con una
bandera neutral y a título individual no
sé si esta es la solución óptima dadas
como está el tema de la Guerra de
Ucrania Qué piensan hay una ventaja es
que el bueno el comité olímpico
internacional solicita pero son las
federaciones independientemente quienes
deciden hay federaciones que desde el
principio de la invasión rusa a Ucrania
no se han opuesto a que los atletas
rusos y bielorrusos sea o sigan en
competiciones el caso del ciclismo por
ejemplo y del tenis y hay otros deportes
que poco a poco o federaciones que han
decidido los dejamos participar o no
pongo el ejemplo de los juegos europeos
que son ahorita a finales de junio que
es como una mini olimpiada o sea
realizan en Europa que da plaza para los
Juegos Olímpicos ellos dijeron los rusos
y bielorrusos aquí no van a participar
no van a poder puntos pero estas
dos naciones tendrán los atletas en Asia
en los juegos asiáticos así no
pertenezcan a ese continente pues van a
estar allá Buscando los puntos para
clasificarse porque ellos Sí podrán
participar pero Siguen sin himno y sin
bandera de su país dice la prensa que
incluso hay federaciones como la de judo
y esgrima que incluso han contratado
empresas privadas para investigar el
pasado en internet de deportistas rusos
para asegurarse de que eran respetado el
principio de neutralidad y no hayan
apoyado a Putin no sé si esto está
siendo una tónica en algunas
federaciones Natalia pensó un poco
porque de hecho además de de lo que
había dicho el coi no de jugar bajo
digamos de presentarse con bajo bandera
neutra la idea también es que
supuestamente deben demostrar que no han
apoyado en ningún momento a la guerra
pero tal vez ahí pues viene obviamente
todo esto es súper complicado con las
federaciones y sobre todo que ante esto
tienen a una persona que no quiere
absolutamente que haya ni bielorrusos ni
rusos compitiendo que ese Sebastián cué
que es el jefe pues del athletics ese
digamos ya la gran Federación de
atletismo del mundo y el mismo que es el
jefe ahí dijo no habrá no los queremos
por ahora no están digamos las
condiciones dadas para que ellos estén
en los Olímpicos una polémica de Hace
unos días la presidenta del comité
olímpico francés dimitió Hace unos días
poniendo fin a una crisis interna y a un
clima insostenible no vamos a explicar
toda la polémica que es un conflicto
interno pero sí que os preguntaría si
esto si esto puede tener repercusiones
todo este conflicto
es muy difícil posicionarse en este
momento porque incluso la batuta de
estos juegos de alguna manera la ha
llevado la ministra de deportes y
ministra de Juegos Olímpicos de Francia
melillo de castera que ha sido la cabeza
visible y el comité olímpico francés de
alguna manera Por lo menos para la
prensa ha pasado a un segundo plano
para ser más exactos sí por lo menos la
cabeza visible Román pero tenemos que
pensar que va a hacer consecuencias
porque hay
pero muchos
de Francia Son Cabos el presidente de la
federación de fútbol fue acusado de Cómo
se dice
sí sí sí sí el presidente de la
federación
ha habido varias políticas de varias
federaciones
así que hay muchas cosas y
hubo una letra abierta
como una carta una carta para pillar una
una pausa cuando todos los asuntos
judiciales de Francia que se dieran un
tiempo que hace en los Olímpicos
va a ser una implicación mucho más
fuerte para Francia como nación
participante de los Juegos Olímpicos que
para los Juegos Olímpicos de forma
general bueno Esto es un asunto interno
francés vamos a ir a cosas más
atractivas hasta 10.000 personas
participarán en el relevo de la antorcha
olímpica que irá desde mayo hasta que
lleguen los Juegos Olímpicos atravesando
muchos departamentos de Francia casi
toda Francia Qué sabemos de este
recorrido por cierto el pebetero de la
llama podría estar en la torre Eiffel
como se ha especulado que piensan
Natalia podría ser porque quieren ellos
que sea una cuestión histórica esa
ceremonia inaugural que mantienen en
absoluto secretos lo que normalmente
siempre se hace así que seguramente
puede ser ese gran gran símbolo ahora
que esperar también porque todo lo ha
mantenido en secreto por ahora solamente
hay algunos detalles en cuanto a que van
a a desplazarse en barcos a lo largo del
del río sena pero bien puede ser una
imagen bastante fuerte de tener un
recorrido que empieza en Marsella si no
me equivoco solo sabemos que empieza en
más como un símbolo de los vínculos
entre la Grecia anticaítica y marcella y
después va a recordar muchos
departamentos y si el final se da en
París en el 14 de Julio que estas están
haciendo y otros se quejan de que no han
podido participar porque el coste que
involucraba lo de la antorcha no se lo
podían permitir el 23 de junio se
conocerá el recorrido completo llegará
como le decías en un barco en un Belén
que es uno de los últimos barcos activos
del siglo 19 de Francia a Marsella 60
departamentos en total y lo bonito esta
vez lo diferente Es que once mil
personas en total la van a llevar un
siete mil de verdad Pero otras como en
grupo en colectivo
otra polémica Ingrid el precio de los
billetes la polémica ha llegado hasta la
asamblea nacional le pregunto ir de
espectador a unos juegos olímpicos es un
lujo exclusivo yo creo que hubo mucha
frustración hablando de la boletería
porque hubo hablábamos muchos de de
plazas y de de precios increíbles A más
de 600 hasta 1000 euros la plata 1700
euros cuánta gente lo puede pagar Sí
pero también se puede ver de manera
gratuita porque como va a andar por el
río sena si estás arriba va a haber
puestos gratuitos totalmente
descubiertos al todo alrededor todo a lo
largo del río O sea que que hay 50 por
ciento es una economía muy particular
muy singular la economía de la
billetería de de los Olímpicos y hay 50%
de plazas que son a menos de 50 euros
bien exclusivo los billetes como lo ven
Bueno hay frustraciones porque
pienso que el sistema de para comprar un
sorteo que se ha hecho
la frustración porque fue
no fue el primer alegado toma los
boletos Pues
un sistema de sorteos bastante
complicado
Entonces
cuando mi familia fue elegida y ya
quedaba solamente plazas a 2.000 euros
para la ceremonia básquetbol a luz 600
euros es usar hay pulsaciones pero a mí
me ha pasado lo mismo
eventos desde el deporte la Copa del
Mundo o de todo son los precios
la seguridad y la ecología son dos
grandes retos de esta cita olímpica
vamos a hablar de ellas a vuelta de
pausa hasta ahora
sarajevo Managua Bali ciudades que como
tantas otras han sufrido la guerra el
hambre La dictadura o catástrofes
naturales
vuelve a las regiones que marcaron la
actualidad internacional
sus habitantes cuentan su nueva vida sus
esperanzas y su lucha para superar un
pasado traumático
acompáñenme en boleto de vuelta Todas
las semanas por France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]
France 24 otro punto de vista libertad
en Primera Plana esta semana analizando
los retos de París 2024 los Juegos
Olímpicos a un año lo hacemos con cuatro
periodistas que conocen muy bien el
mundo del deporte Ana María ospina
Natalia Ruiz y Ingrid sellen la
seguridad y la ecología son dos grandes
retos de esta cita olímpica que no
podemos dejar pasar la seguridad
empecemos por ella en esa ceremonia
inaugural que es donde están puestas las
miradas a orillas del sena va a ser un
rompecabezas de dimensiones sin
precedentes al aire libre tantos miles
de personas Natalia y de hecho se hace
unas semanas ya se firmó lo que es el
protocolo para para esa ceremonia entre
la ciudad del estado y el comité
organizador y justamente uno de los
puntos es precisamente sobre la
seguridad porque lo que quiere la
organización en un principio querían
600.000 personas allí Pero obviamente el
Ministerio el interior les dijo a nivel
de seguridad es muy difícil es un
desafío muy grande sabiendo que va a
haber 20 barcos a lo largo de todo ese
recorrido que son unos seis kilómetros
sobre escena donde va a ser barcos
únicamente que van a encargarse de la
seguridad pero a esto tienen que
encargarse del resto de seguridad habrá
Vips todo todos estos jefes de estado
jefes de gobierno que van a estar
presentes entonces viene esto y viene
también un cierto número de de personas
de seguridad de privada dos mil o tres
mil que además están buscando Quienes se
puedan ocupar estas plazas están incluso
Llamando a las personas aquí en de la
agencia de de desempleo para decirles
Bueno hay formaciones disponibles
necesitamos agentes de seguridad para
evitar por ejemplo lo que ocurrió en la
final de la de la Liga de Campeones el
año pasado en el estadio de Francia
entonces viene toda ese dispositivo que
es muy importante pero por ahora digamos
que no hay digamos un algo en detalle
exactamente de Cuántas personas van a
necesitar allí otra polémica el medio
ambiente la ecología los organizadores
de los Juegos Olímpicos de París 2024
aseguran que reducirán las emisiones de
gas de efecto invernadero a la mitad
serán unos juegos tan ecológicos como
dicen sus organizadores o aquí siempre
que sospechar
95% que ya están hechos que no hay que
construir O sea que faltan solo cinco
que están bien renovar poner a las a las
normas ecológicas actuales los estadios
que ya existen solo hay la piscina y la
Villa Olímpica que hay que que ya está
construido Pues claro la forma más
ecológica de situarse en el mundo es lo
que no se consume lo que no se construye
lo que no hay que hacer No es muy
importante la herencia lo pensaron y
todo el edificio donde vaya a ver los
atletos y todos Ya están pensando a
mover las paredes para volver para que
se vuelvan apartamentos para más tarde
los Olímpicos de 2004 no saben entonces
han pensado desde el principio el
proyecto como como reutilizarlo después
y eso
pienso que es bueno vamos a hablar de
Novedades entramos en terreno deportivo
Qué significa Ingrid la gran
especialista Qué significa la entrada
del break dance Y qué puede aportar pues
significa mucho Yo creo que es de hacer
verdaderamente el punto de atracción
porque hay 32 disciplinas sportiva
olímpicas 28 ya están establecidas y
cuatro son escogida por la ciudad que
que recibe los Olímpicos O sea que París
escogió la escalada la el Surf y el
sketball que ya estaban en Tokio pero
escogió el Breaking y eso fue una
novedad porque bueno es una disciplina
que nació en Estados Unidos al final de
los años 60 pero ya en los años 80 en
Estados Unidos ya todo el mundo pensaba
que se había acabado pero era sin contar
a Europa donde donde ya habían Los
Pioneros que estaban adictos y que
hicieron crecer a esa a esa cultura a
esa disciplina Breaking Ahora somos
múltiples campeones en Francia de de
Breaking O sea que era la evidencia que
es experta cuando nos pongamos delante
de los televisores y veamos Breaking la
gente que no está habituada que no está
acostumbrada al Breaking
algunos consejos para verlo con unos
ojos que hay que Manuel básico en tres
consejos a ver pues los jueces tienen
van a tener una nuevas tabla para juzgar
tienen que pasar una certificación todo
eso es nuevo no existía antes una
certificación que se llama trivium para
poder juzgar y van a mirar Body Sol en
Mind que es lo más son los criterios los
más esenciales el van a mirar el feeling
la potencia la de la musicalidad el
ritmo del del competidor O sea que va a
ser complicado pero van a tener muchas
cosas que ver y van a estar muy
sorprendidos por el Breaking París 2024
contará con skateboarding y con Surf que
fueron dos disciplinas que debutaron en
Tokio 2020 esas olimpiadas las cubrieron
Natalia De qué depende que algunas
disciplinas sigan Y de qué otras no
sigan bueno todo depende lo que decía
Ingrid No ese la ciudad que organiza los
juegos la que decide también y en
función muchas veces de el país y de
algunos deportes en Japón por ejemplo
está el softbol y el béisbol que son dos
deportes supremamente importantes y que
ya luego aquí en en París no están pero
falta saber si de pronto dentro de
cuatro años o bueno cinco en Los Ángeles
por ejemplo regresa el béisbol en vista
de la popularidad de ese deporte allí
igual Ahorita lo hablábamos Igualmente
había el taekwondo y el taekwondo salió
el karate perdón el karate y el karate
salió vino estuvo en Japón y ya aquí en
París no está así que hay como esas
entradas y salidas y un poco también de
como de tristeza también por parte de
los de los atletas que tienen esa
posibilidad olímpica una vez y una vez
no Aprovechando que tengo aquí cuatro
periodistas deportivos les voy a
preguntar Ingrid está claro que de lo
que va a estar pendiente del Breaking
pero Román de todas las disciplinas
en tulupa de periodista deportivo qué te
interesa más
picos la izquierda
porque me volvió un aficionado desde
Tokio y también el ciclismo porque soy
un aficionado de ciclismo Entonces
no sabemos todavía el recorrido que van
a hacer pero se habla de
que puede ser algo fantástico que subía
a bicicleta Entonces eso son los dos Ana
quisiera estar pendiente de dos
novedades olímpicas Más allá del break
dance es una nueva categoría en el boxeo
femenino la prueba de atletismo que va a
sustituir los 50 km y la maratón para
todos que es un evento abierto en el que
el público de todo el mundo
clasificándose podrá hacer el mismo
recorrido atletas amateurs puedan hacer
el mismo recorrido que los atletas
profesionales no el mismo día pero el
mismo recorrido y sentirse como si
fueran parte de los Juegos Olímpicos
Natalia
yo me voy a ir por él por el BMX en
tanto en Racing como en Freestyle que
son dos disciplinas bastante
interesantes Hay buenas oportunidades de
medalla además por para el uso de
latinoamericanos Así que esas son dos de
las que voy a estar pendiente Y
seguramente el atletismo que siempre es
algo supremamente emocionante
de acuerdo de unas olimpiadas Es que
ejercen de ventana para que la gente se
pueda aficionar a cosas que nunca
pasarían por su cabeza no sé cómo
explicarlo no te encuentras viendo algo
en televisión una competición de algo de
un deporte que de otra forma No
llegarías a ella Ingrid Sí sí es es lo
interesante es que vamos a ver y vamos
todos a descubrir disciplinas y mirar
campeones que no conocemos del otro de
las otras partes del mundo y va a ser
supremamente Interesante
pero podemos tomar como ejemplo escudo y
esquema porque siempre
los Olímpicos hay nuevos licenciados
siempre se ve en Francia nuevos
licenciados porque el equipo de Francia
es muy buena en estos disciplinas ese es
un escaparate muy potente Ana algo muy
bonito los Juegos Olímpicos que el
deporte vehicular ese mensaje de Unión
internacional bueno Eso suena muy
publicitario pero es más que nos permite
descubrir a veces nuevos países porque
hay cambios geopolíticos nuevas banderas
cuando vemos la inauguración los himnos
de otros lugares los idiomas Entonces el
Esto es lo que nos permite el deporte y
los Olímpicos Más allá de que haya
descripciones deportivas también crean
públicos y hago énfasis en los juegos
paralímpicos que serán justo después de
los Olímpicos donde vemos atletas que
realizan su deporte y personas que nunca
en otro mundo se imaginarías y quedan
con alguna discapacidad poder hacer
parte de una fiesta olímpica paralímpica
en su caso una pregunta importante en
estos últimos minutos qué determina que
unos juegos olímpicos una cita con los
Juegos Olímpicos sea un éxito y me la
cabeza el ejemplo de Barcelona 92 que
siempre se ha considerado como un éxito
o un fracaso Como tantas otras de costes
de desperdicio de todo qué criterios
tenemos para determinar el día de mañana
que la historia sitúe a París 2024 en el
en el campo del éxito Natalia yo creo
que una parte es lo que lo que viva el
público si el público sale contento ve
que pudo transportarse de un lugar al
otro en París para ir a ver diferentes
competiciones va a quedar contento
también ya va a ser tal vez a nivel del
de los gobiernos de las ciudades de si
los sobrecostes se fueron exagerados o
no y luego también en cuanto a los
resultados también los récords mundiales
que vayan a abatirse a lo largo de de de
los Juegos Olímpicos eso también puede
venir a a sumarse como éxito de de unas
olimpiadas
sean catalogadas como éxito o fracaso yo
creo que también además de todo lo que
lo que dijiste ahí toda la seguridad
tenemos tenemos Ese es muy importante la
seguridad y la organización la
organización la seguridad como ahora hay
drones hay cámaras inteligentes hay la
Inteligencia artificial también que
viene a a ponerse ahí Tenemos que tener
una seguridad perfecta y que no porque
hubo hace poco con el el fútbol muchos
muchas polémicas de falta de seguridad
me imagino que es importante que huella
deja en la ciudad
en las olimpiadas a Barcelona la
campearon completamente hubo un antes y
un después en Barcelona 92 no pasa
siempre así no
los Olímpicos desarrollan los deportes
en el país donde ocurre el mundo
fue un suceso un éxito
lo siento
porque hay mucho muchas disciplinas
donde
Inglaterra se volvió mejor
después de los Olímpicos que antes y los
inglesas son muy buenos para eso porque
pasa lo mismo con el fútbol femenino
ahora de qué depende que hay que
cateloguemos el día de mañana París 24
como unas olimpiadas de éxito es la
huella que deja en la ciudad por eso se
hace en este momento mucha inversión en
zonas hasta ahora consideradas un poco
marginales aquí en Francia las censan
Denisse que es uno de los departamentos
más pobres de este país es donde está la
Villa Olímpica donde hay varios lugares
deportivos y es lo que luego le va a
quedar a esa sociedad lo que les va a
ayudar a construirse a ser parte
sentirse parte de esta fiesta pero
también parte de este país y es lo que
les va a quedar a ellos como herencia O
sea que hay una huella de mejora social
no les pregunto también a nivel
deportivo es importante para el
organizador Francia quedar bien en el
medallero por supuesto esa es una de las
del es decir sería digamos el grano
perfecto una gran organización
exitosos y también lograr las medallas
Francia por ahí puso creo que 60
medallas fue lo que dijo el presidente
de Manuel
menos de la mitad
bueno
Natalia hemos hablado con unos técnicos
son muy pesimistas con este objetivo es
que este objetivo y tienen demasiado
tarde para lograrlo
Bueno pues veremos si tiene si consigues
esa marca a mí me parece tremendo 80
medallas Pero pero bueno habrá que verlo
queda ya un poco más de un año para esa
cita olímpica Ya ven muchos retos ha
sido un placer comentarlos con ustedes
en esta mesa hoy de Primera Plana hasta
aquí nos despedimos volvemos la próxima
semana aquí en Primera Plana de radio
Francia internacional y de France 24
Muchas gracias